today on the matt walsh show a teacher
admits publicly that he's afraid
online learning will interfere with his
ability to brainwash his students and
many other teachers chimed in to agree
with him
when the school system says this sort of
thing out loud
uh we should listen also five headlines
including more looting in chicago and a
controversy over a trolls doll that
seems
sort of silly at first until you take a
closer look which we will
and in our daily cancellation i will
cancel nasa
uh for putting social justice ahead of
space exploration i don't want to have
to do it cancel nasa but i have to
and we will today all of that on the way
but first let me tell you about our
sponsors uh legacy box legacy box is
a very simple mail-in service to have
all of your home movies and pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive dvd
or
the cloud don't let those priceless
family memories disappear because
that's what happens if you don't take
action uh it really is it's that simple
it will go away are your family's
memories trapped on old
camcorder tapes or film reels remember
magnetic stripes uh
magnetic stripes are degrading and not
made to stand
the test of time so let the science be
the solution especially because disaster
happens you know
it's an unfortunate reality and one that
no one can ever really prepare for
don't let your memories fall victim to
the disaster
digitize those memories now i can tell
you that uh i have
taken many of our old memories preserved
in antiquated formats
formats that lead them leave them
vulnerable to becoming degraded or
destroyed
you have a flood or something you've got
a box of old tapes
well those are gone so i've digitized
those memories with
legacy box and just the experience of
getting the legacy box
in the mail is a lot of fun and it's
really special i can tell you that
listen the process from start to finish
is extremely easy
you pack you send their team digitizes
everything
by hand send it back to you you enjoy
simple done easy simple as that
everything is digitized by hand at their
secure eight acre digitizing campus
they use premier scanners and playback
decks to ensure
each memory is mastered to the highest
quality
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of
worlds of home movies and photos and has
helped over 850 000 people
get those memories stored just like that
get started
future proofing your memories today so
you can gather the family and begin the
trip down memory lane go to
legacybox.com
walsh to get an incredible 40 off your
first order buy today to take advantage
of this exclusive offer send in when
you're ready so you buy today you send
in when you're ready go to legacybox.com
walsh and save 40 while supplies last
okay in one of the creepiest yet most
revealing twitter threads
ever to be posted on the platform i
think a teacher recently fretted out
loud
that virtual classes might allow parents
to hear him brainwashing
their kids and he's very afraid of that
matthew r k
an educator and author of a book called
uh
how to lead meaningful race
conversations in the classroom
worried that quote conservative parents
would be able to
interfere with the quote messy work of
indoctrinating children into critical
race theory
gender theory and other left-wing dogmas
here's the entire thread which has since
been set to private but here's a
screenshot of it
it says so this fall virtual class
discussions will have many potential
spectators
parents siblings etc in the same room
we'll never be quite sure who is
overhearing the discourse
what does this do for our equity slash
inclusion work
how much have students depended on the
somewhat secure barriers of our physical
classrooms to
encourage vulnerability how many of us
have installed some version of
what happens here stays here to help
with this
while conversations about race are in my
wheelhouse and remain a concern in this
no-walls environment
i am most intrigued by the damage that
helicopter
snow plow parents can do in the in the
host conversations about gender
sexuality and while conservative parents
are my chief concern i know that the
damage can come from the left too
if we are engaged in the messy work of
destabilizing a kid's racism or
homophobia or transphobia
how much do we want their classmates
parents
piling on
that's what he had to say it's important
to note that
while some teachers responded to kaye's
comments with the appropriate level of
horror and disgust
many others chimed in to share their own
strategies for brainwashing
during a pandemic apparently this is
something that the teachers have thought
about and
have come up with strategies for one
teacher said that
she'd also been quote thinking about the
problem that kay described and
had decided that she'd ask her students
about their preferred
preferred pronouns via survey uh though
she still worries that
uh quote caregivers might see it and
learn something about their children
that they weren't supposed to know
apparently another teacher said that
students last semester would sometimes
uh quote type
secrets into the chat whenever the
discussion turned to quote anti-racism
and gender inclusive content
another complained that a white parent
she made sure to specify
white in her district recorded a zoom
class
and then quote filed a complaint against
the teacher for anti-racist
for a r for an anti-racist read-aloud
saying the teacher's commentary was
inappropriate and biased
and this the teacher says is going to be
an issue
a 9th grade teacher shared shared in the
commiseration
saying that her class required students
to quote
read and respond to a news article as
part of her class
but that participation in this exercise
is stunted now because
quote outsiders are listening
the outsiders to be clear are the
children's parents
and another teacher with pronouns listed
in her twitter handle so you know what
she's
up to said that she plans to use the
chat function
more than voice lectures because she
wants children to quote
share that information with her in a
quote parentless way
then a science teacher agreed with all
the sentiments expressed here
but summarized it bluntly saying parents
are dangerous
and these are just the comments that
were captured in screenshots
before the tweets were all made private
presumably there is more where this came
from
a lot more now
i think several points should be made
here
in response first
this may seem like a side issue compared
with the very large problems unwittingly
or maybe not so unwittingly exposed by
the thread but
it should be said that that classrooms
are certainly not
safe places for children to be
vulnerable
students may say and do things when
they're with their peers in school
that they wouldn't say and do at home
but only a fool who doesn't understand
the first thing about child psychology
and the effects of peer pressure
would assume that the child's at school
version of himself is the most authentic
much less the most healthy the the
pressure to conform to the values and
opinions of your peers in the classroom
is immense and overwhelming
and often suffocating for these kids
there's a reason why rejection and
alienation by peers has contributed to a
true epidemic of suicide
among young people suicide is
skyrocketing among young people and in
fact
the very same people who extol the
classroom as a safe place for
vulnerability
will also tell us on different days and
in different contexts
that bullying is a major problem at
school for today's youth
and many of them are driven to
self-destruction because of it so
which is it is the classroom a place for
open and genuine dialogue where children
can safely express their truest
feelings and beliefs or is it a place
rife with bullying and mockery where
rigid conformity is demanded
and those who fail to meet the demands
are severely punished it certainly can't
be both of those things
and the answer is that is it's much more
the latter than the former
second point an adult
keeping a secret with a child
and helping the child conceal that
secret from his parent
especially when the secret has anything
to do with sexuality
is acting in a way that is nothing short
of predatory
now if you heard a strange man on the
playground whisper
to your child this will just be our
little secret okay don't tell your mom
and dad
you would assume that the man is some
kind of sex offender and respond
accordingly
does this behavior suddenly transform
from disturbing to admirable if the
strange man is a teacher
no it doesn't but this is a sort of
license that society has given to
teachers
on the theory that they cannot do the
work of educating unless they have more
power over
and intimate knowledge of their students
than the
students own parents do which brings us
finally to
point three which is that a public
school teacher
is not supposed to be and should not try
to be
educator parent shaman spiritual guide
therapist friend confidant and sex
counselor all rolled into one
he is meant to fill only the first role
of educator
and only in the subject that he's been
assigned to teach so it's very limited
a child's actual parents can only become
to be viewed as
dangerous and intrusive and outsiders
when teachers begin to view themselves
in the school system as the true
guardians and and conservators of the
children that are temporarily in their
care
and that ultimately is the problem with
the modern education system
children are not old enough to be
emancipated
they can't go out and and live their own
lives
they can't make every decision for
themselves or even most decisions for
themselves
they must belong to someone
not to say owned like objects but cared
for
and protected like the vulnerable and
relatively helpless human beings they
are
the fundamental question is who do they
belong to
different cultures in different times
and places have had different answers to
that question
here in contemporary american society
there are generally two ways of looking
at it
children belong to their parents
or they belong to the school system
which is to say the government
in one vision a child is a son or
daughter in the other the child is a
ward of the state
only one of these visions is healthy
natural and humanizing only one can
properly facilitate
a child's emotional mental intellectual
and spiritual growth
the school system doesn't just have a
wrong and harmful idea of what education
is it has a wrong and harmful idea
of what a child is and what its
fundamental role in a child's life is
supposed to be
and that is why i will not be sending my
kids
into the education systems clutches and
neither should you let's move on to our
five headlines
as we get into five headlines here i
want to tell you about uh one of our new
responses on the show
car shield you know when you want to get
something fixed on your car
it can be uh terrifying to consider what
the bill
might be we've all been through this
it's uh it's not a very fun waiting game
where you send the car in
and you're just waiting around waiting
to get that phone call
find out how much it's going to cost
computer systems and cars are the new
normal from electronically controlled
transmissions to touch screen to play
displays to dozens of sensors and all of
that is
it can be good but you know you can't
fix any of those features by yourself
so when something breaks it could cost a
fortune and now is not the time for
expensive repairs
car shield has affordable protection
plans that can save you thousands for
for a covered repair including computers
gps electronics and more
the people at car shield understand
payment flexibility is an absolute must
especially these days monthly plans can
be customized to your needs with rates
as low as 99
a month no long-term contracts or
commitments car shield gives you
the options that others won't you get to
choose your favorite mechanic or
dealership to do the work and car shield
takes care of the rest so you still have
the power to make those choices
um and they're also going to offer
complimentary 24 7 roadside assistance
and a rental car while yours is being
fixed so all of that comes with it
car shield has helped over 1 million
customers and why don't you be
1 million in one for as low as 99
a month you can protect yourself from
surprises and save thousands for a
covered repair
car recovered repair call 800 car
6000 that's 800 car 6000 and mention
code walsh or visit
car shield.com and use codewalls to
save 10 that's car shield.com code walsh
a deductible may apply okay number one
chicago mayor lori lightfoot was uh
out this weekend serving and protecting
the the citizens of chicago
uh and lightfoot found a dangerous group
of law
breakers who uh she she was sure must be
brought to justice
and well let's just take a look um
here's here's what she tweeted
it's a picture of a bunch of shirtless
guys and speedos
standing around in the grass near a lake
i guess and she says
it's called a pandemic people this
reckless behavior on montrose beach
is what will cause us to shut down the
parks and lakefront
don't make us take steps backwards and
then she follows up in case you were
wondering i stopped by to see for myself
it's being addressed yes
um the shirtless speedo guys at the lake
they're the they're the problem here
take care of them
you know because that's that's the real
issue it's them
and not this what you're seeing here is
looting in chicago again last night
they were looting all over the city no
compensate
in many of these videos uh because
lightfoot has them focused you know on
the speedo problem and not the looting
and rioting problem
um you know not the problem of anarchy
and destruction raining down on the
street
again and again and again and again and
again night after night after night
after night if you're curious by the way
they're doing this
ostensibly because police shot a guy
who had a gun and had shot at them
the guy didn't even die as far as i know
but there was a guy with a gun
shot at police police shot back
he got hit and now they're
rioting because of it because police i
guess are supposed to
at this point they're supposed to just
drop their guns and just
offer themselves up to be killed just
walk up to the bad guy and say okay i'm
here
do what you will anything less than that
is oppression but you just look at these
and um you see these these
the footage here uh you know this is
this is obviously this is a fascist
dictatorship
where cops murder people in the street
and all of these poor protesters live in
fear because of it
yet every night people casually riot and
loot and stroll aimlessly out of burned
out retail outlets
with armfuls of stolen shoes does that
make a lot of sense to you
does it make a lot of sense for for you
know a woman who who's
wandering out of a coach store with a
box of stolen purses
saying i live in fear of the police
i live in fear that the police will come
anytime and kill me
is is that what you do with it i mean if
you're being oppressed and you live in a
fascist dictatorship
and you're worried about police who are
prowling the streets just looking for an
excuse to kill somebody
this is how you respond i mean
are these people who who really seem to
be afraid of authority
no it would seem like the problem is
very much the opposite
number two let me just give you the
headline here from the daily wire it
says hasbro
pulls troll doll amid concerns that toy
normalizes sexual exploitation
that's the headline and i have to tell
you my wife
um informed me of this controversy the
other night
and and uh said that there was some kind
of thing about a trolls doll
and my immediate reaction upon hearing
that was to think that's just another
example of people being hypersensitive
and dramatic
not to mention i thought if somebody
actually sees a trolls doll
and and ties it into anything
sexual well that's just a reflection of
their own perverse
mind okay that's like get your mind out
of the gutter
that's what i thought until i saw the
video
of the doll in action and uh it kind of
changed my perspective
a little bit in order to take it out of
demo mode
you have to the instructions say to sit
doll so you put her legs
out and you sit her down
for five seconds which by doing that
um he pushes the button
but now
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i cannot believe that like this is
insane
yeah that's that's uh
disturbing that is definitely disturbing
now hasbro claims that they place the
button there because it's it's supposed
to make those noises when it sits down
but first of all why would it make those
noises when it sits down
is that does that make sense since when
does sitting down
[Music]
elicit sounds like that from from anyone
even a troll second
even if there was uh you know even if
there were innocuous intentions behind
this
how could it be that nobody at hasbro
through the whole process of
manufacturing and distributing this
thing
how could it be that nobody anywhere
ever went
uh guys this is a button in the
doll's crotch area
that causes it to squeal when you touch
it that's uh
that's weird guys like how did nobody
think of that how did nobody
point that out see here's the thing i'm
never perplexed by
uh individual people doing stupid things
that doesn't
ever surprise me and i'm also not
surprised by whole groups of people
doing stupid things all at once like
we've seen in our streets across the
country
uh and in chicago last night so none of
that like stupidity and mass hysteria
okay neither of those surprised me i get
it that's how people are
but what what always does surprise me a
little bit is when you've got a
succession of individuals
making a considered choice and that
choice
right down the line is horrendously
insanely stupid
that's when i scratch my head because
you don't really have the mass hysteria
element
and it's not just one person so there's
a right there's
checks and balances here and right down
the line i mean literally down the
conveyor belt
nobody noticed anything wrong with that
um now some people are saying this was
done to intentionally advocate child sex
trafficking or whatever
you know i think that theory is a little
bit intense
um i go back to hanlon's razor which is
never a tribute to malice what could
easily be explained by stupidity
and so i think that probably applies
here but either way it is uh
very weird to say the least number three
i'm going to play this for you with no
setup just
just watch if you look at like the 1990s
and the way that
rush limbaugh and others sort of sharpen
their teeth on bill clinton
this has been the way they've built
audiences for three decades now
yeah i don't want to claim it's new i
just i'm arguing that it's getting worse
it's getting more severe uh aaron your
view of this you know
when you see um entire media companies
essentially exist
to tear down joe biden is there an
equivalent to that on the left tearing
down trump
uh there really isn't and you know what
i would say it it's a it's really a diet
of this
type of information that a lot of these
voters are getting a lot of the voters
that i talk to i can uh you know when i
interview them i do hear
uh them saying a lot of the talking
points that sound very familiar from
from some of these shows which i try to
listen to
when i'm out on the campaign trail or
when i'm at home you know watching tv
you know you can you can hear these uh
these comments being echoed
uh by voters and you know that this is
the diet that they're on uh
you know am radio uh you know
conservative talk
uh also social media i mean the trump
campaign is running a full-blown
campaign on social media that is
completely
off the radar for for a lot of a lot of
uh you know regular media
is not covering this but i mean you have
folks laura trump
kimberly guilfoyle katrina pearson the
campaign is is running you know kind of
a parallel
campaign online and and if that's all
they're getting you know to the
exclusion
of of kind of the more traditional
legacy media uh you know then
it really is no surprise kind of what
their understanding is of this country
and of our politics
such an important point though simply
amazing that they could
keep a straight face throughout that
exchange
is astounding i mean this is really this
is like
a guy dumpster diving naked chowing down
on
like a soiled diaper maggots all around
old banana peel on his head comes back
up and says you know when you see people
in drive-thru lines at sonic
i mean that's really unhealthy that's
that's that's got to be the most
unhealthy diet in the world right
it takes another chomp of the diaper
just the self-awareness level here is
arctic levels this is sub-zero okay
self-awareness
uh number four cnn is trying to whip up
a race controversy
and i know that you hear that statement
and it's rather evergreen okay you hear
that and you think oh so it's monday
okay
but let's be more specific uh here
here's the latest fake race controversy
from cnn
reading now from their article says a
black student was forced to take off his
black lives matter face mask in order to
graduate his family says
dean holmes a student at york catholic
high school in york pennsylvania put on
a black lives matter mask under his face
shield at his
july 28 graduation ceremony as students
lined up before the ceremony started the
school's principal pulled him away in
front of the other students
and told him to take off the mask holmes
had previously been told
by uh by another school official to take
the mask off so he eventually relented
for fear of not being able to walk
across the stage he said
uh holmes said quote i was so mad i was
shaking during the graduation tapping my
leg on edge
when it was over i couldn't believe it
york catholic had opted to give every
student a facial instead of a mask for
the ceremony holmes's father
john took to facebook on saturday saying
that the school stifled his freedom of
expression and jeopardized his health
the capricious this is the john now the
capricious action taken against my son
demonstrates that york catholic high
school has miles to go before they can
put the ugliness of unconscious bias and
racism to sleep
as a parent i will not stand for my son
being humiliated publicly
having his basic human dignity crushed
on what should have been one of the
happiest days of his young life
okay a few things to cover here first of
all
john holmes calm down you drama queen
basic human dignity crushed because he
couldn't wear his favorite face mask to
graduation
his human dignity is crushed because of
it that's how you crush a person's
dignity really
well if your sweet precious child's
dignity is hinged on
something as superficial and weird as
his face mask
that's a different issue okay he needs
counseling for that
also dean holmes calmed down
you drama queen you were shaking really
you were so sad and upset you were
shaking because of this
because you couldn't wear your favorite
face mask what kind of man
shakes when he's upset much less admits
it publicly
you're the one crushing your own dignity
i agree your dignity has been crushed
but by you not by the principle
also most importantly just so you know
the school has a policy nobody
is allowed to wear anything to
graduation that has
any kind of message on it nobody
that's been the rule at the school since
always and it makes sense
they don't want graduation to turn into
an event to advertise political
viewpoints
or any other viewpoint and they want
uniformity that's every graduation i've
ever been to and i've been to quite a
few
that's how it is everybody looks exactly
the same there was a there was a there
was a hubbub
at i don't think it was at this school
but at some school a couple years ago
when a student i think was at a college
wasn't allowed to wear his uh his
military dress
blues across the stage at graduation
and even there i would say i mean
obviously it's
a wonderful thing that he has the
uniform and that he serves this country
but
at the graduation this is it's a
different uniform and everybody's
supposed to look the same that's the
point
so there's a dress code is the point and
everybody is held to it
no exceptions it's a dress code you have
to just follow the dress code like
everybody else you're not special
why should dean have gotten an exception
because he is
is he special why is he special because
i know he's daddy's special boy but does
that mean why should anyone else care
about that
give me one good reason why this
particular person should be exempt from
the dress code
that everyone has always been expected
to follow
that's what dean's father that's what
john
holmes is saying here what he's saying
is yes there's there are rules and
there's a
there's a dress code but my son is
special he shouldn't have to follow the
rules
this is my special son oh shut up
this is this is this i mean among other
things this is terrible parenting
you're the father you you should be the
one your son
is crying and shaking because he had to
follow a dress code
as the father you're supposed to be the
one smacking some sense into him
instead of going to facebook
you'll never believe what happened to my
boy
shut up number five
finally the national park service posted
to facebook a couple days ago
um giving advice on what to do
if you come across a bear and they say
if you come upon a stationary bear move
away slowly and sideways and this allows
you to keep an eye on the bear and avoid
tripping
moving sideways is also non-threatening
to bears do not
they say run but if the bear follows
stop and hold your ground like dogs they
will chase fleeing animals do not climb
a tree both grizzlies and black bears
can climb trees
do not push down a slower friend even if
you think the friendship
has run its course now i know this last
comment about the slow friend was meant
to be a joke right
uh but i just want to say this uh you
know this is not a joking matter
and they shouldn't be making light of it
um yes you absolute obviously you
absolutely should not push down
your slow friend if you come across a
bear
that would be an awful thing to do um
because if you push him down then he'll
be in a submissive pose and the bear
might not attack him
and may keep pursuing you instead so if
this is this is really a point if your
friend is slow
there's no reason to push him down let
his slow
dumbass keep running you go off in the
other direction and the bear is going to
go for him i mean this is just basic
now if there's something you can do to
slow your friend down further without
stopping him from running so let's say
for example
you're in a lake or something and you
come out of the lake and uh there's a
bear
there so one thing you could do is grab
his shoes
and run off and now that's going to slow
him down hinder him a little bit
and then when he gets mauled and killed
by the bear the bonus is
you also now have a new pair of shoes so
i mean these are things you could do i
just i was really disappointed
that the national park service had an
opportunity for a real teaching moment
here
but instead they went for the joke and
that is as i said
just really really disappointing we're
going to go to our daily cancellation
now but first
i want to tell you about our most
exclusive membership tier over at the
daily wire which is all access all
access members get to join all access
live which is our exclusive live stream
q and a's hosted every night by each of
the hosts including myself i'll be doing
one tonight as a matter of fact
um you also get not one but two leftist
tiers tumblers with your membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
uh
access to daily wire products which you
saw last week with our limited
count collector's edition baseball bat
available only to all access members and
those things went really quickly so
head over to dailywire.com walsh right
now to get 20 off all access with coupon
code access that's deliwire.com
walsh with coupon code access to get 20
off your membership today for our daily
cancellation we're going to be canceling
nasa it seems that with elon musk and
other private entrepreneurs
taking over the job of actual space
exploration nasa has
had to find other things to do rather
than explore the vast
unknown of space going where no man
woman or non-binary person has gone
before
and expanding humanity's understanding
of its own place in the cosmos nasa now
has
plunged itself into a different sort of
lethal vacuum and that is
far-left activism two examples of this
shift
one hilarious and stupid the other even
hilariouser and stupider
first a far-left professor ibram x kendi
who wrote a book about
systemic racism called how to be
anti-racist
which that teacher also wrote a book
just like that so it's i mean there's a
lot of books a lot of books
on this subject and he was invited to by
nasa to give a talk to its employees
uh just to be clear kendy is an expert
on critical race theory which is like
being an expert on the greek gods or any
other mythology
but he is not an astronaut nor does he
appear to have any expertise on subjects
that astronauts would really need to
know unless they happen to encounter
institutional racism on the moon i
suppose here's the email that nasa sent
around to its employees
the email was obtained by the daily wire
and uh it says this again was sent
by nasa to its uh employees it says
the only way to undo racism is to
consistently identify and describe it
and then dismantle it writes professor
ibram x kendi
that is the essence of anti-racism the
action that must be followed both
emotional and intellectual awareness
of racism ibrax kennedy is a renowned
historian and author of how to be
anti-racist
professor kendy will speak to the nasa
workforce on wednesday october 12th or
august 12th rather from 12 30 to 1 30
via ustream now if you're wondering
how these eight anti-racist strategies
will be employed
well here they are in action nasa uh
tweeted i guess kind of you know
practicing what it preaches
nasa tweeted this over the weekend
here's the tweet it says
and this this by the way is not a joke
okay just so you know this is not
photoshop
as we work to identify and address
systemic discrimination and inequality
in all aspects of the scientific
community
we are re-examining the use of
unofficial terminology for cosmic
objects which can be not only
insensitive
but actively harmful the link brings us
to an article on the nasa.gov website
which
we'll go through a little bit of this
article here because like i said it is
hilarious
it says in part distant cosmic objects
such as
planets galaxies and nebulae are
sometimes referred to by the scientific
community with unofficial nicknames
as the scientific community works to
identify and address systemic
discrimination and inequality in all
aspects of the field
it's become clear that certain cosmic
nicknames are not only insensitive but
can be actively harmful
nasa is examining its use of unofficial
terminology for cosmic objects
as part of its commitment to diversity
equity and inclusion
and then it continues as an initial step
uh
nasa will no longer refer to planetary
nebula ngc
2392 the glowing remains of a sun-like
star that is blowing off its outer
layers at the end of its life
as the eskimo nebula eskimo is widely
viewed as a colonial term with a racist
history
imposed on the indigenous people of the
arctic regions most official documents
have moved away from its use
yes okay sidebar here for a second you
notice
the phrase widely viewed as
they didn't say that eskimo actually is
a colonial term because well
it definitely isn't it is according to
the alaska native language center
an inuit term which means neter of
snowshoes
it is not offensive it is not a slur it
is not colonial
it is not racist but it's widely viewed
as racist and therefore we're told
it is racist but this is not how reality
works
okay look at it this way there are two
adults and four kids in my family
it would be accurate to say that in my
house ice cream
is widely viewed as a magical food
source that you could eat for breakfast
lunch and dinner every day forever
and still live a long and healthy life
those who hold that opinion
outnumber the alternative perspective by
two to one
yet despite how it's viewed if my kids
were able to live according to their
views on this point or frankly on any
other point
they'd be dead in a month okay because
that that's how reality works doesn't
matter how it's viewed
the reality is the reality any case the
name of the nebula has been changed and
so
um now finally those who have been
traumatized by the existence of an
eskimo nebula 36 quadrillion miles away
can rest easy knowing that the sky above
them as they sleep is a little less
racist
other changes are also being made um
going back to the article because you
know there's there's a lot of
offensive bigoted names in space
apparently
it says nasa will no longer use the term
siamese twins galaxy to refer to
ngc 4567 and ngc 4568
a pair of spiral galaxies found in the
virgo galaxy cluster
moving forward nasa will use only the
official international astronomical
union designations in cases where
nicknames are inappropriate
okay another sidebar how is this
offensive
siamese twins is a name that comes from
a famous set of conjoined twins in the
19th century
siamese referring to their land of
origin what what what's offensive here
exactly
is the name racist because it refers to
a place
is it that i mean is that all it takes
for it to be racist now
or is it offensive to actual siamese
twins
why would it be offensive to siamese
twins for them to be acknowledged in
this way
i thought it was offensive not to
acknowledge marginalized people
so which is it should we honor the
marginalized by taking their names off
of stuff or should we honor them by
putting their names
onto stuff or both or maybe we employ
one strategy on even days and another on
odd days i mean how does this work
exactly
but it gets even more ludicrous if you
can believe it okay
it gets even worse listen to this it
says
nicknames are often more approachable
and public friendly than official names
for cosmic objects such as bernard
33 whose nickname the horsehead nebula
invokes its appearance
but often seemingly innocuous nicknames
can be harmful and detract from the
science
okay wait a second it's not clear to me
here exactly but are they saying that
horse head nebula is offensive too
is that i'd like to say no they're not
they're clearly saying that it's
approachable and friendly
but i just i don't know anymore you
could never assume you can't assume
any ounce of rationality or common sense
when it comes to leftists you just can't
so it seems that they might be saying
that horse head nebula
is offensive to who exactly
deformed freaks with horse heads is it
offensive to them or actual horses or is
it offensive to the nebula itself
because it's body shaming i don't know
well all we know is that thomas
zerbuchen associate administrator of
nasa's science mission dictoriate
uh or directorate victoria i can't speak
but you can't point it out because
that's offensive to me at headquarters
in washington says
our goal is that all names are aligned
with our values of diversity
and inclusion and will proactively work
with the scientific community to help
ensure that
science is for everyone and every facet
of our work needs to reflect that value
and you see this is the rub right here
nasa's
values are diversity and inclusion
why i mean i know why i i ask why
rhetorically as a figure of speech so i
mean why
in what way does diversity and inclusion
help nasa to fulfill its proper function
its proper function which is according
to its own website
to quote drive advances in science
technology aeronautics and space
exploration
to enhance knowledge education
innovation economic vitality
and stewardship of earth that's a good
function if you ask me
it would be great if nasa did that stuff
i remember when nasa did do that stuff
and if that that being exploration and
innovation
is its mission and its goal then in what
way precisely does diversity and
inclusion advance it
in what way does a greater focus on
political correctness
advance it in what way is it advanced by
a commitment to social justice
if anything all of that only interferes
with proper functioning it certainly
doesn't aid it by any stretch of the
imagination
but just think about it what sort of
attitude do you need
to go out into the great unknown and
explore well just look at neil armstrong
buzz aldrin these were brilliant highly
skilled
men but they were also extremely tough
men
and men who especially especially in
armstrong's case
didn't care much for other people's
feelings
this is the profile of pretty much
every explorer ever in history brilliant
courageous tough even at times brutal
ambitious single-minded perhaps
obsessive
this is the kind of attitude and
approach that's necessary to achieve
great things
and to do what has never been done and
to go where no one has gone before
what about innovation i mean what do you
need in order to innovate what sort of
people do you need for
that well you need again brilliant
skilled people also you need
courage different kind of courage often
but you need courage
you need people who are focused who are
driven people who think differently
people who can
look at problems from from an entirely
new perspective
so so once again if you're if you're
nasa
how does a focus on diversity and
inclusion help you find
those kinds of people it doesn't at all
if you want to find those kinds of
people you look for
those kinds of people whatever they
happen to look like
whatever of the 198 genders they happen
to be
you find people who can do the job and
that's it
i can't think of any arena in which
diversity and inclusion matter
less than in the arena of space
exploration
it is the most irrelevant and ridiculous
consideration
as it always is in all contexts but
especially in this one
so nasa is canceled
and that's the end of the show today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the andrew clavin
show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton
you